why this talk today uh we all agree that
that cryptography is hard and it is hard
on multiple levels
from like understanding what's going on
to like
implementation itself and then
there are so many ways to make a mistake
and mistakes are bad right
we all agree on that
and today we're going to talk about how
to exploit some of these mistakes in
crypto
we're not going to talk about zero days
um
there's no information about that in
this presentation
there will be no complex math at all
there will be just a few basic really
basic things
we're not going to talk about the dark
future of cryptography
which
is probably quantum stuff that's going
to break everything
and we're not going to talk about how to
break correctly implemented crypto
because by definition
it is unbreakable today might be
breakable tomorrow but today if
everything is implemented correctly it
is unbreakable
so my name is alexey and um i'm a
software developer in the past i spent
over a decade writing code primarily for
one big company and then i kind of
switched gears and started doing more
security stuff
in application security world
starting the same company and then
moving into some security consulting and
i currently work for salesforce
i have
several certifications in
security that are listed here but the
most important thing on this slide is
this
i am not a cryptographer
so i
i don't consider myself a cryptographer
i probably don't know much about it
i just come to this topic strictly from
practical perspective
as a hacker and
um
you you would realize
going through this presentation there is
nothing really
deep and
complicated here but there are some
practical things that we all can do in
order to exploit some mistakes
so general recommendations upfront
when
doing crypto we need to use well-known
and secure algorithms right we all know
that we are not supposed to use des
because ds is no longer secure
okay
the second thing is
we should use standard and stable
libraries meaning
good implementations of those algorithms
right we don't use some obscure library
some code that you downloaded from who
knows where
and just run it you
you pick up a library that's well known
that's well maintained
and does not have known security bugs
the third thing
is very important you need to follow the
best practices
and that's
basically
a
very broad and deep topic
and it really depends on
what cryptographic scheme you use what
algorithm you use what you're trying to
do
there are certain things that we we all
need to understand and follow
and the last but not least do not invent
your own crypto and you have heard this
advice
hundreds of times but just wanted to
throw this in
um here again
in terms of common mistakes
the first one is
insufficient entropy meaning there is
not enough randomness
and randomness in crypto is very
important
many times
when we deal with
cryptography
we we need a good random number
generator and when we look at some data
they might the data might look like
a random noise and and that's great
that's awesome
anything
in those cases that doesn't look random
enough
is probably an indicator that
things are not done right
the second one is algorithm choice
meaning we use a wrong algorithm we use
a chainsaw where we need a hammer or
vice versa
so that's very important to know and
understand
and the third one that's that relates to
those best practices so when we pick up
an algorithm and that's the right
algorithm for the right purpose
we need to understand
what exactly we need to do here like
if there is an iv
what what's that iv where do we get it
and so on where do we get the key how we
store the key
what mode we use and so on so on
number four
it's often overlooked but we tend to
focus on confidentiality right we all
want to protect the data we don't want
anybody to read but we often forget
about integrity
so is the message trustworthy okay we
encrypted it but can somebody actually
modify it in the way that we don't
want
so integrity is really really important
and the last but not least is key
management you can do everything right
but
if you don't manage the keys correctly
your keys get leaked your keys get
cracked or
some
or obtained in some other way and your
whole scheme is broken
okay this is the math for today
exclusive or or xor this is the only
operation
a mathematical
operation that i'm going to talk today i
call it the ultimate crypto weapon and
you'll see why so but before we go there
the uh
you all know xor but just to reiterate
it here here is a table on the right
that
uh that kind of
like on the bit level
shows the
uh the operands and the results
and there are a few interesting
properties
of xor the first one is anything xor
with zero is the same thing doesn't
change
anything xor itself is zero
and if a x or b
equals c
then a x or c equals b and b x or c
equals a so that means you can move that
operand to any side of the equation and
it still holds true
okay let's talk about randomness
in terms of random number generators
there are two big classes of them the
first one is called true
random number generator
and these are
[Music]
things that are non-deterministic and
they create unpredictable results
the
two random number generators are usually
implemented with the help of hardware so
there are some there's some input that
is impossible to predict like for
example inbin temperature or
noise or
i don't know electric current
fluctuations
you name it but uh basically that's
something that really does not depend
on the computer itself it's some kind of
an input from outside that you can
convert to to random numbers
and there's also pseudorandom generators
these are deterministic
meaning that if you run it you you if
you give it a certain input you know
exactly what the output is going to be
and they're seed-based
so you seed
your random number generator with
like say a random number right and and
it will give you a zero random stream so
why why do we have two and not just one
the problem is the
true random number generators are pretty
slow and it's very difficult to get a
large amount of data from them
pseudo-random generators are fast
and they usually used in
together so we get a we use trng to get
that seed and then we seed prng with
that seed and we get a stream
all right
a few years ago somebody decided to
write a ransomware for linux the
ransomware at that time was already
popular for other platforms and some
people thought well okay enough with
hacking windows let's do
let's attack linux now
so they wrote this ransomware
called linux encoder and
what happened is it was immediately oh
well almost immediately
how to say
the people were able to find an issue
with with that ransomware
because it depended on predictable
encryption keys they did not
use good entropy source and it was
possible to
to decrypt all the files
without paying the ransom
and let's see a demo for that i do have
a demo for that
by the way a lot of this presentation
today will be live demos
so um
follow up and also
at the end i'll give you a link to the
github repo where you can download this
code and play with it yourself and see
what's going on analyze it modify it
do whatever you want
okay
so we have
a document
it's a text file that says not all
random functions were created equal
awesome
and we're going to encrypt it
and ask for ransom so now this
document.ransom
is
some kind of binary data well it's in
its encrypted file
um
we don't store the key anywhere
if you look at the encrypter
you'll see that they seed the
pseudorandom number generator
with the current time
which is very very bad idea
and why is that
because
the
this file that's written on the disk has
a timestamp the timestamp is
with high probability exactly the same
as the timestamp that was there at the
time we were getting the seed
so in order to decrypt this file without
knowing the key
all we need to do is to get the
the
file modification
timestamp
and
use that as a seed for random number
generator
and decrypt the file with that so let's
see if that works
and it worked perfectly
we were able to successfully decrypt the
data
and we got the original text and that's
exactly what happened with that linux
encoder
ransomware they they use the current
time to see the random number generator
again very bad idea and here's a good
advice
of course it's sarcasm
doing md5 on current time does not give
you any advantage at all
so
again
this is bad advice don't use time
okay let's talk about
encryption algorithms
there is this encryption algorithm that
is not used these days it's called
one-time
pad let's say we have a message m and
the key
k
the encryption would be a simple xor
operation so the cipher text here c
is m xor k and that's it that's all
there is to this encryption algorithm
and how how is that even encryption
well there is a theorem
that says that if key
is
uh random
then the
uh
the key exhort with anything will also
look like random and there is no way
to
uh to recover the original message just
by having
the ciphertext
well decryption due to the properties of
xor
is
the opposite operation so we just xor
the cipher text with the key again and
we get the original message
so that's this is very very simple
algorithm
and here's just an example
of ones and zeros in the message in the
key and in the ciphertext
so
why is this algorithm not used these
days well the obvious thing
obvious problem is that key has to be as
long as the message so if you want to
encrypt a gigabyte of data your key has
to be one gigabyte long and that's very
impractical
the second problem
is in the name it's called one time path
for a reason
why why one time
well apparently if you encrypt two
messages with the same key
there's an issue
if you if somebody intercepts those
ciphertexts
they can xor them
and due to the properties of xor the key
would cancel out and they would get an
xor of the original messages
this might not seem like a big issue but
it is
and
because um the again the attacker can
gain a lot of knowledge from
just intercepting ciphertext and in some
cases
that's enough to break the scheme
okay
uh
these days we use
instead of one-time pad we use stream
ciphers
so
what is stream cipher
instead of having
an infinite key we have a finite key and
we give it to a generator function
this is basically serial random number
generator
so
our finite key of say 16 bytes becomes
an infinite key stream
and then encryption is the same as in
one-time pad we just
xor
message with that
uh key stream
and decryption is
again the same thing we xor ciphertext
with the same key
but again we can see here that we should
not reuse keys because
again we'll have two messages encrypted
with the same key
uh we xor them together and we get the
i mean we extort the cipher text and
we'll get the xor of original messages
i i wanted to know that modern
implementations of stream ciphers do
introduce some
randomness
so it is
these days i would say it's safe to use
the same keys but in the classic sense
um each
we should not um yeah i mean there are
there are additional ways to additional
ways these days in modern
implementations to protect from these
kind of attacks but
let's see what happens if we use an
older algorithm
and encrypt the same message with the
same key
i mean two two different messages with
the same key okay
i have
i have visual example here
i have two pictures
one picture is of myself and the other
picture is of a smiley face
cool so let's try to encrypt these two
images
with the same key
okay
all right
so now in addition to these two images i
also have
two
two other images that look like random
noise and these are encrypted images
like if i just look at one i i cannot
tell anything about it like
there is really
it really looks like random data
okay now looking at the source code
we're using rc4
algorithm which is
again it's an older algorithm i do not
recommend using it today
but for the sake of this example
i'm using it here just to demonstrate
we generate a key once and then we
encrypt two images with the same key
all right now let's see what happens
when i xor these two images how do i xor
them
i'm going to open them
in a graphics editor and this particular
editor
allows me to do an xor operation so
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to
paste to images
as layers here on the right hand side
you can see that i have two layers
the first one is
the the first encrypted image the second
one is the other encrypted image
this editor allows me to perform layer
operations and one of them happens to be
xor it's right here
so if i extort them together
see what happens
i
like
i as a human can immediately
not see just one message but both
messages i can see that one of them was
a portrait of a person and the other
was a smiley face
so it's
to me it's
immediately recognizable so the the that
xor operation of the two cipher text
reveals both messages to me
moreover if i open
if i happen to intercept
one of the original messages like for
example if i happen to know that one of
them was this smiley face
i can add it as
a third layer
and apply xor operation again
and i get the original message
that is uh
that is that is a photograph
so again i have three layers here random
random
random
and
a smiley face
and when i extort them three together i
get this like this is
mind-blowing right
okay cool you get the idea
okay in additional to stream ciphers we
also have block ciphers so stream
ciphers
work on on bits you can encrypt
single bit at a time
block ciphers work on blocks they you
give it a block of bytes and
it does permutation based on the key and
gives you cipher ciphertext which is
another block
well uh
usually the data we want to encrypt is
longer than a single block it's longer
than 16 bytes or whatever right so we
need we need to do something about that
the most obvious and most
straightforward way to do that is just
to
to split the message
in multiple blocks and encrypt them all
separately
and that might seem like okay but
uh
if you think about it
if two
plaintext blocks like block one and
block three happen to be the same then
the two ciphertext on the output will be
the same
and
so so the cipher text is no longer
random you can see patterns there
and and again patterns in cryptography
are not good not good at all
let's see what happens when we encrypt
something with uh with a wrong mode like
this one
like this ecb
again i have a visual example
i have this image
which is a screenshot of the title slide
for this presentation
okay
and
i'm going to encrypt it and this script
encrypts it twice first it encrypts it
with cbc mode which we have not
discussed yet
and it also encrypts it with ecb mode
and here is the script it generates a
key it does not store the key anywhere
it encrypts files and equips the file uh
two times with different modes
so let's see what happens
here is the image encrypted with ecb
mode
as you can tell it's
even though it does not exactly look
like the original image
you can completely understand what was
there right i we as humans can
immediately like instantaneously analyze
it and just
so called decrypt the original message
right
in contrast here is the cbc encrypt
encrypted image
and that looks like random noise to me
and there is no way for me to understand
what's going on here
so what is this cbc the cpc introduces
randomness
at for every block it uses
a result of previous block encryption so
it like for example uses this cipher
text to
to feed the next
encryption operation
so the cipher text is xor with
plain text and then
the whole thing is encrypted and so on
and so on
but for the first block we don't have
the previous block so we need something
else and that something is called
initialization vector which is just a
random number and it doesn't have to be
a secret it just has to be random so you
you generate it when you encrypt and you
can send it along with ciphertext you
don't have to encrypt it
but it's it's used to to kind of to kind
of seed that encryption operation to
introduce randomness
and then you use it
during decryption
so decryption decryption is the opposite
operation
at each step the previous
block is used to
xor with the result of decryption to get
the original plain text
so if we have
the
[Music]
the encrypted message of three blocks
um c1 c2 and c3 then the decrypted
blocks would look like this right
so we would decrypt a block and then we
would x or it with
in
in in the case that in the case of the
first block we would accord with iv
second block would extort with with the
first block and third block will xor
with the second block and so on
okay
now
i
one one mistake that some people make
and
i've seen it down
so this is not just theoretical but it
has been done and
it's not a good idea
so okay we we need this initial
initialization vector
and we need the key so we kind of need
to two inputs to our encryption
operation
or decryption operation
so why
the question is why can't we just use
the key
as initialization vector
well uh
for one it's it's kind of random right
and uh the second thing is it's secret
so we don't even have to send it across
with the data because whoever is
receiving the data and decrypting it
already knows it
so people try to cheat and do that and
this is not a good idea because let's
see what happens
again let's say
an attacker intercepted
encrypted message consisting of three
blocks
so if an attacker
we
can modify the encrypted message and
resend it
so it's a man in the middle right and we
send it to the one who receives it and
gets something
back as a result so we
we consider
certain assumptions here which are often
considered in cryptography
like in this case we can modify this
cipher text and uh we can also
ask the decrypter to decrypt it for us
okay so the attacker builds this
instead of c1 c2 and c3
they create c1
zeros
and c1
and then they give it to decrypter so
when the
the receiver decrypts that
here's what happens
the result of the first decryption
operation on the first block is
basically xor with the key because key
is the same as ib ib is used a key is
used as ib
the result of the second block
decryption
is this and we don't care
what it is
but the result of the third
block decryption is xor with the
previous block
and it's all zeros so it's just this now
if we take that
and this and xor them together
we get the key
so if
if we can do that not only
like we can we cannot decrypt
the the message but we can just get the
key and then we can decrypt the message
and let's do a demo on that
so for this one
that's not the right one okay here it is
i have
a web application
that gives me a session cookie
so this session cookie happens to be
if i look at the source code
let's let's assume the source code is
open anybody can analyze it
so i'm looking at the source code i see
that the session is a very simple object
it has
two
two fields user and role and
for for the guest user
which is
me right now the user is set to guest
and then uh when
when i go to this website the next time
the this session cookie is analyzed and
if the user is admin then i get access
to the administrative page and if not i
get i only get access to the guest page
here
we can see that the cookie is
encrypted and is encrypted using as
algorithm which is a good algorithm
we use
cbc mode great
but we use key as iv
let's see what can go wrong
so i have this cookie value that was
given to me by the server
first thing i need to do is to build
that
really weird
encrypted message right so instead of
the original one
i get this and those a's in the middle
are the is our zero block
now i get i
get uh get that copy that and i refresh
my page so that
now this
this new cookie value will get decrypted
on the server side
and of course
uh it's not decrypted properly because
there's some garbage here
but
the server is
nice enough to tell me about it
and even give me basic for
representation of the decrypted string
and
all i need to do now is to put that into
my other script
to retrieve that key
so what are these forge and get key the
forge is
like very simple you know we just built
a message using three blocks
okay and the middle one is zeros
and the get key
is
again a very simple operation it's just
basically an xor
this is a bitwise xor
how do i know that this is the correct
key well since i since i run the server
on
on my machine
i can just print that session key which
is stored in the file and you see that
it's c4 f1 e0 fb
which is exactly matches what i was able
to retrieve as the user who does not
have access to the server
cool
okay the other problem with block
ciphers is it only acts on blocks right
so you you need to have your date your
yeah your data
the length of your data has to be
multiple of the block so you can only
encrypt
16 bytes or 32 bytes or 48 bytes and so
on
but your message is not always exactly
multiple of the block size
so what happens then so
what happens then is we use so-called
padding
let's say we have this message of
10 bytes
but we need 16 because our block size is
16 this is not good
by convention we just pad that message
with six extra bytes
and each one of them is set to six
so when you decrypt
this and you see
that your last block is
ends with six
sixes
then you can just throw them away you
truncate that message because this is
this was padding
and padding works great for block
ciphers
one problem with padding
is
um
well with with implementations of
of uh encryption of decryption
using block ciphers is pattern oracle
what is paid in oracle so let's say your
server who processes
encrypted data so you receive ciphertext
you know the key you decrypt it and then
of course you would check the padding
and
to to know whether you you need to um
to trim that message or not
and if the padding is is not okay
it's reasonable that you give some kind
of error message saying that your
message was corrupt or whatever
if everything was okay you continue
now the problem is if you
let the user know about this
they
they they can
basically decrypt
anything without knowing the key
how is that possible
that might sound like
a strange thing how can you decrypt a
message without knowing the key okay i
have a padding oracle here which runs as
a web application
this application accepts encrypted
messages it gives me an example if i
refresh the page
you can see that the message changes
every time well actually it doesn't
change it's just it uses a random iv
every time okay
the key stays the same but
the ciphertext changes because of random
iv
so if i
click on this
this this encrypted message gets sent in
the url
and it's decrypted by the server
it gets processed i i don't know how it
gets processed but
um
what if i try to change this last byte
it's eight let's let me set it to zero
okay
and send it if i send it like that i get
invalid message the title says
unauthorized
okay let's look at the code
the code
just decrypts the message using as
algorithm using key and iv using cbc
mode everything's good
it's
unpadding that message
to throw that those petting bytes
out
and it
of course this is within try block
and it catches the value error exception
meaning something got wrong during
decryption
and we just say your message
was was bad
unauthorized whatever right
and nothing like
just by looking at this code you
wouldn't assume that
anything was done wrong here but this is
enough for
an attacker to decrypt message
well i already said it like three times
let's see how it works
my exploit
accepts
the
this url
and what it's going to do it's going to
retrieve that that encrypted message
here byte by byte
and it didn't take too long did it so
here is the original message padding
oracles are real
and as as you can see it started to be
the first block
and starting with the last byte
and here's s here's e s
l
l-e-s
c-l-e-s and and so on and then it
proceeded to be the next byte
and retrieve the rest of the data
like how did it do it
let me run it again
and this is the back end this is these
are the requests on the server so
basically this exploit sends hundreds
of requests to the server each time a
single bit gets well
a byte while um is modified in a certain
way
and by just trying different different
bytes
it either gets an error
or
like pattern error or not no pattern
error and
using that information
it's able to retrieve the original
message here's the exploit and we're not
going to go into details on how this is
implemented you're welcome to study it
on your own or
contact me and i'll help you with
but it is possible it is real and these
attacks
are
uh where implemented in in the wild and
i mean this is this is real stuff
not just
theory okay
like i mentioned earlier we often tend
to focus on confidentiality and forget
about integrity
integrity is again extremely important
let's say we send a message that says
send 100 to alice we encrypt it
but an attacker
intercepts it and modifies it
so when the message is decrypted
it says send 100 to mallory
and alice doesn't get anything
so is that possible
for to do even without knowing the
encryption key is it possible to modify
such message
when it's encrypted but you don't know
the key well the the answer is yes
in some cases
this is this is often called this
philippine attack and how does it work
if we have if we use a stream cipher
and we
remember that stream cipher is just a
simple xor operation so let's say our
original message was guest
maybe it's a session cookie right
so we are guessed it is encrypted
so this the the included message is
the original message
export with the key stream
right okay
so attacker intercepts
this message
modifies it
instead of the original
so so that ciphertext
gets xored with guest because the
attacker knows that if
it says guest
but the goal here is not to decrypt it
because it's already known the goal here
is to modify it so the unsuspecting
server
thinks that
i'm admin right so okay i xor it with
guest and accord with admin why am i
doing it
now let's see what happens on the server
whether when this message is decrypted
what is decrypted is simply xor with the
key stream okay
which expands to this
so this uh new ciphertext is basically
this thing
okay
now this original ciphertext is expanded
to this
now guest and guest cancel out
key stream and key stream cancel out
we get the admin
and i do have a demo for that
okay
again i have a very simple web
application
this time
it's giving me session cookie encrypted
differently not
not like here right
but
if i delete this cookie
let me see if i can delete yep and
refresh the page
i get a different cookie value well
basically it's the same
data encrypted again
it's just encrypted using
a new
stream cipher called salsa 20.
and i'll show it to you here's also 20.
and this implementation is using nons
nonce is
is that randomness that i mentioned that
is introduced in stream ciphers
so
you know to help with stuff like key
reuse
so okay but
in this case i don't even care what the
nonsense i don't i don't even care what
the key is
i can still modify this message because
there are no integrity checks here
when the message is decrypted
it's decrypted right here
right
it's just converted to json and i mean
from json to internal object and then
the it gets validated against admin
all right
so i can use that bit flipping attack
my
exploit
just gets that
that ciphertext again it doesn't care
about the encryption key or the nonce
it needs
to know the original plain text
i can look at the source code and
analyze and understand
what what it is right it's user and the
date but conveniently it just prints it
here so i'm just going to copy it from
here
and
i need to put down my desired plain text
the desired plain text is
admin
i want to be the admin
moreover if i look at the source code i
see that
the date parameter is not even used
so i can just completely get rid of it
all right so here is my new
message that i want the server to
believe
okay
cool bit flipping done here's my new
cookie
copy to my browser try it again
now if i refresh the page
i'm the admin
well
it was easy with stream cipher but
apparently the same thing is possible
with block ciphers too because block
ciphers are using
initialization vector or iv
so especially if you're trying to modify
that first
block
it's it can be done trivially and
we're not going to go into details on
this but it's basically the same idea
because we xor with iv
then so we can modify that iv and submit
a new one and our new message
will decrypt to what we want
and i have a demo for that too but i'll
leave it up to you as an exercise
when you go to github and download my
source code
so
to ensure integrity
um
what we use is called authenticated
encryption
authenticated encryption
ensures confidentiality integrity and
authenticity
that means it is protected like
people cannot decrypt it if they don't
know the key but it's also protected
that people cannot modify it
if they don't know the key
the authenticated encryption generates a
so-called authentication tag
and that authentication tag is
verified during decryption
and if it doesn't match what it's
supposed to be
then an error is generated and
we did not proceed we did not trust that
data
that is not authenticated
so very very important
to remember again uh
when when you're doing crypto
make sure that you consider this
not just confidentiality but integrity
in many cases
not is not just as important as
confidentiality but in some cases it's
way more important
and the last topic that i wanted to
uh to talk to discuss today is turn in
the passwords
three things number one
we all know that we should not store
plain text passwords right because
because they can get leaked
not a good idea rule number two we
should not store decryptable passwords
okay we decided we're going to create
encrypt but we should not use
the encryption algorithms that you can
apply to decrypt and get the plain text
password because sooner or later your
encryption keys will get leaked
or compromised in some other way and
you'll get the attacker will get access
to the passwords and rule number three
we should not use one-way hash
and you might think
what
um
i thought everybody was saying that we
need to encrypt passwords one way
right yeah that's true but some people
take that advice
literally and they use one-way hash
to
store the passwords
and why am i so specific about this
well there's a big difference between
one-way hash and the other thing which
is also one way but it's called kdf or
key derivation function that's the thing
that we need to use for passwords
here's the difference
hash is cheap meaning it's fast
right key derivation function is
expensive
it can it
can be expensive in terms of
time or cpu usage or memory usage and
sometimes
all of them
why is it important is because if
somebody is trying to crack your hash
they can do it easily if you use a
one-way hash function like sha-1 for
example
or even shot you whatever right because
it's by definition it's fast they can
iterate through thousands of
maybe millions of hashes per second
if you use kdf it becomes really
expensive they can iterate through a
handful of hashes per second and it's
very impractical
and just so you appreciate that i wanted
to show you a demo
i have a
hash generator script
and
it can generate sha-1 hashes i think
it's sha one let me double check
oh no it should shout to 56 cool
yeah shot 256 is a great hash algorithm
it's
it's uh secure for its purpose right uh
it's even using random sold
everything is good right
here is the
generated file here is the
here is the hash
right
now
if i want to crack this
i can run
different tools in this case i'm just
running john the ripper
boom and my password is pink floyd
and it only took a fraction of a second
right
to crack this password because it's it's
so simple it's it's in the it's in the
dictionary
and
it's in this
this dictionary and
the tool was able to iterate very
quickly
to show you the difference let me
generate a hash for the same password
using pbkdf2
and
just
just to mention ppkdf2 is not even the
latest and greatest
of these but just just to demonstrate
let me run gender ripper
on this
and you see it's taking longer already
first of all it's running it decides to
run eight
threads
to crack
and it's not returning yet
it's gonna take
a few more seconds
in my
at least in my previous text tests
it should eventually okay here it
returned
yeah the password is pink floyd he was
able to crack it but
it took it took way longer took like 23
seconds and here are the stats
it was the tool was only able to iterate
through
44 passwords per second and in the first
case it was able to iterate through
100 000 passwords per second
you can see it's a huge huge difference
so it becomes very impractical to
to do it for if if you store the
passwords
using a good function
so take aways
if you're a breaker you need to
understand the concepts of crypto on the
technical level yeah it's not just i
mean
sometimes it's it's enough to just know
the best basics but
in most most of the times you need to
dig a little deeper
you need to examine the industry
guidelines
they are there for a reason
if
they say
a random iv needs to be used then it's
there for a good reason and if you see
that it's not being followed then
there's probably something wrong and
it's probably
it could be exploitable
you can expand on other people's work
there are some tools
there are some
there are papers
there are talks conference talks and and
whatnot and you can always use
the experience of other people to build
up on
if you're a builder
you need to understand the crypto
concepts you don't necessarily have to
dig deep
but
you need to understand
why
um
what what you're doing and your tasks
tasks specifically like
if if you're storing the data
you want to encrypt it what algorithm
you need to use what keys how you store
the keys
what the encryption mode you use and so
on and so forth
and
of course follow all the guidelines
again they're there for reason if if we
don't follow them then we potentially
open up ourselves to
all kinds of bad things
and
learn from other people's mistakes
if
sometimes things like things get
published like
if something was done wrong like
you can you can read about that and see
what exactly was wrong
and don't do that
for further learning
i i would highly recommend this course
on coursera it's free
i'm not affiliated with coursera or
whatever but i just happened to take
this course a couple of years ago and it
was awesome
i believe it's still there the second
thing is uh there is this
free book
it's a
it's like open source project but it's
basically a pdf that you can just
download and read
uh
it's awesome awesome overview
for
in order to understand
some
well
it covers lots of things from really
basic to some really deep stuff highly
recommend
as i promised my code is on github you
can just go to this url
get downloaded play with it
and let me know if what you think let me
know if you wanted to
add something here i would be happy talk
to you and good luck in your